hey guys Dennis here and WBU has dropped
some huge news today following cop the
comic-con news that Warner Brothers was
going to produce a Batman vs Superman
theme Man of Steel to everyone
speculated about who's going to be
playing batman / Bruce Wayne and they
finally announced today that it was
actually Ben Affleck so originally they
had wanted Ben Affleck to direct Justice
League and during that time people were
speculating that that possibly been was
going to play Batman as well as direct
Justice League and after he turned down
that job the the speculation the rumors
of him playing Batman kind of went away
but apparently WB was still very
interested in getting him as Batman
personally I was hoping for Karl Urban
Guy Pearce Luke Evans or someone like
that so Ben Affleck was definitely not
in my top choices however I have to say
after an announcement I don't hate it
I'm not jumping up and down saying it's
the best casting ever but at the same
time I'm not with the rest of the
internet going crazy saying they ruined
Batman this is the most worst thing ever
to ever happen but you know I mean we
had George Clooney play Batman and
George Clooney is a good actor but his
Batman was terrible I think Ben
Affleck's is a very good actor he
doesn't always show it I think he hasn't
made always the best choices there's
certain movies that paycheck that that
he took not for the right reasons but
lightly in the past several years you
know it's been 10 years since daredevil
he you know with his directing efforts
he's he's much more passionate about
those and and he starred in the last two
movie two of the three movies that he
directed and I think he did a great job
in both of them a my little hesitant and
concerned yeah a little bit because
things could you know obviously go wrong
I i buy him definitely as a Bruce Wayne
but I'm more hesitant on the Batman side
you know whether he can pull that off
being kind of like
tough and intimidating but you know that
I said the same thing and everyone says
the same thing about Michael Keaton and
also heath ledger's joker so I'm
definitely going to keep an open mind to
it so those are my thoughts let me know
yours you can post comments it on this
YouTube video below you know what do you
think about Ben Affleck being cast as
Batman who would you rather see play
that role you also can follow me on
Twitter that's at think hero and we also
have a Facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash stinky row fans and
our website to that's think eurocom